[Musique]
aujourd'hui j'ai calculé que je vais
devoir attendre encore 3888 jours avant
de devenir adulte est trop belle
je me demande comment ils sont arrivés
sur le terrain vague et d'où ils
viennent je vais mener mon enquête et
percer ce mystère
c'est de la folie où william a il faut
reconnaître que c'est fascinant
allez c'est parti ça alors qu'est ce que
je vois un pingouin est sous mon énigme
c'est qu'étant sens capable de
mystérieuses créatures ont été aperçus
dans notre région il s'agit là d'un
phénomène totalement inexplicable au vu
des circonstances
des adultes sont en train de fouiller la
forêt je voudrais tellement faire
quelque chose pour qu'ils reviennent
je sais ce qu'il me reste à faire
complètement chamboulé
[Musique]
on est pas humaine ne pleure pas aux
gamins
ouais
[Musique]
on